les conservateurs choisissent leur chef
en fin de semaine et la manière de voter
est vraiment complexe
laissez moi vous expliquer
les 13 candidats conservateurs doivent
amasser des points chaque
circonscription vaut 100 points il ya
trois cent trente huit circonscriptions
donc un total de 30 3800 points toutes
les circonscriptions ont le même poids
peu importe le nombre de membres qui
vive pour l'instant c'est simple mais ça
se complique un peu ça si le bulletin de
vote conçu les 250 9000 membres du parti
et c'est à partir de ce qui sera écrit
sur ses bulletins que les points seront
distribués les membres doivent classer
en ordre de préférence sur dix candidats
favoris le parti va tout d'abord
calculées les premiers choix et dans
chaque circonscription l'appui obtenu
sera transférée en point par exemple 30%
des votes ça fait trente points pour
gagner il faut qu'un candidat accumule
la moitié des points disponibles donc au
moins seize mille 900 points mais dans
cette course des candidats il y en a
beaucoup et donc il faudra fort
probablement plusieurs tours avant de
trouver un gagnant
certains croient que 8 ou même dix tours
seront nécessaires mais c'est difficile
à prédire
à chaque tour le candidat qui a la moins
bonne performance sera éliminé les
points qu'ils avaient obtenu ce candidat
là seront redistribuées et ce sont les
candidats qui avaient été inscrits comme
deuxième choix par les membres dont le
candidat est maintenant hors circuit qui
vont obtenir ces points on continue
comme ça
tour après tour jusqu'à ce qu'un
candidat soit élu chef
vous suivez toujours avec ce système de
vote il ya deux éléments clés
l'importance d'avoir des appuis partout
au pays
même dans les régions qui sont moins
conservatrices parce que chaque
circonscription compte ayant un poids
égal mais il faut aussi être perçu par
les membres comme un bon deuxième ou
troisième choix et donc comme une
personne qui est rassembleuse des
facteurs qui pourraient brouiller les
cartes et créer la surprise